well blood banks here in southern nevada
and across the nation are in dire need
for blood donations they are still
trying to level up for pre-pandemic
numbers victoria saha explains why it's
so important to donate regularly even as
you may never know when you or your
loved ones could need a blood
transfusion
at red cross southern nevada the donated
bags of blood on the shelves are a bit
of a relief for now blood can't sit on
the shelves for more than about 50 so 55
56 days so this comes through pretty
quickly rachel flanagan the executive
director of red cross southern nevada
says their worst fear is seeing the
shelves empty
just like they did last year some of
those folks they need up to 100
transfusions a year of the 60 percent of
the population eligible to donate she
says only 3 percent do we saw declines
over the summer people traveling and so
everybody's just kind of getting back to
school and doing all those things that
they need to do from trauma patients
surgeries cancer treatments blood is
used in every department for our local
hospitals i constantly see a need for it
long-time donor and hospital nurse
nicole bai says her first-hand
experience pushes her to donate blood
every eight weeks and there are times
where we have to wait
several hours days just to get them the
help that they need
donating is pretty simple and it really
just feels like a pinch but there are
some restrictions standing in the way
for potential donors the red cross's
website listing sexual identity getting
a tattoo in the past three months
certain diseases and a certain travel
outside the u.s as limiting factors
they have been offering more incentives
to get people to donate like gift cards
and t-shirts and no matter if you're a
first time donor or regular donor each
donation can save up to three lives
victoria saha 8 news now